what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another talking Thrones Q&A
video I recently made a post on my
YouTube community tab and I asked all of
you to leave me some more questions
because of my last Q&A video I was only
able to answer so many I received more
questions this time than I did last time
so thank you all for that I will start
this video off by answering some of the
questions that had the most likes but I
will also answer a few of the newer
questions that didn't get as many likes
just to try and mix it up some so let's
get started right away the first
question that received the most likes
was from Golden Lions why was Arya
allowed to leave the faceless men that
never set right with me how they just
let her go yes she earned it but still I
thought it was a lifelong thing this is
a good question but the problem with
this question is we may never find out
exactly why Arya was able to leave under
those circumstances I can certainly make
a few guesses but instead of me
answering this myself I found a quote
from the actor and he gave his own
answer for why he allowed Arya to leave
the actor who plays Jack and agar sat
down with Access Hollywood and they
asked him why he allowed Arya to leave
Braavos alive and this is what he
actually said to him it was always
obvious that Arya trying to be no.1 was
like a teenager trying to deny who they
are in order to be one of the popular
kids and that the faceless men are using
that for their own ends in my opinion it
was clear from the beginning I mean
that's the reason he trained her he
didn't train her to become a faceless
man and to stay in the house of black
and white and Bravo's forever I think
that the faceless men they certainly
have an interest in what's going on in
Westeros otherwise why would he have
just shown up out of the blue in season
2 and picked Arya and offered her to
train her so there must be some sort of
interest and I think yeah what's the
point of training her if she can put
that training to use he also gave a
reason why jaqen smiled at Arya after
she killed the wife he said he's
pleasantly surprised to see that Arya
took to the training so well she killed
the wife that's why in the end when he
realized she'd managed to escape the
waif and kill her he was also pleased
because his student had
old when he first met her he immediately
recognized the potential in her she
posed as a boy and everybody but him
believed it and so already when she was
a little girl he could see that she had
quite some talent to do these things or
to become a different person and when
she left Westeros she was still a little
girl and now over the course of her
training she's grown up and now she goes
back to Westeros and she's a totally
different yeah she's a totally different
person she's an adult he's basically
saying that he knew Arya would never
stay in Braavos forever when he first
met her he took interest in her because
he could see that she was already trying
to become someone else to hide her own
identity then Arya saves his life so he
ends up becoming fond of Arya and he
takes her under his wing but he always
knew Arya would eventually go back to
Westeros to put her training to use I'm
hoping that dead answer your question a
little bit because I think his opinion
would be better than anything I could
have said I'm sure the writers gave him
some hint as to what the whole point of
the training was the next question is
from Montez hutchinson how does House
Stark produce errors and not become
extinct if bran doesn't become brain
again this is a very good question and
it is one that does concern me a little
bit I actually did make a video about
this before but in my opinion the Starks
are going to need to figure this out
soon even if bran does become brain
again he still may not be able to have
kids we don't know exactly how bad his
injury was if bran is completely
paralyzed from the waist down he
probably can't have sex but I guess we
will never know until the show confirms
or denies this personally I don't think
Bryan ever will have kids so in order
for the Starks to produce an heir it's
gonna have to come from one of the other
stark children and this is where things
can get complicated the only member of
House Stark that is sexually active
right now is Jon Snow
I believe if any of them are going to
produce an heir it's going to be John
but the only problem is Jon has a
bastard name and he's about to find out
he's actually a Targaryen
so if John and Daenerys do have a child
together they're gonna need to decide
which last name they will give it they
could technically legitimize the kid and
give it any lies name they choose John
is a king and Dany is a queen so they do
have that power to do this by
the question is will they I'm hoping the
writers of this show bring this up in
season 8 because this should be a
concern for House Stark
even if Sean's and Aria had a child
their baby would typically carry the
father's last name but neither of them
are in any kind of a relationship right
now with only six episodes left it would
be kind of weird if one of them all of a
sudden produced an heir and this is why
I think it would need to come from John
if they plan on answering this question
before the series ends I really don't
know how the writers are gonna solve
this problem I think in the season 8
finale they might imply that Sansa or
Oriya is about to be in a relationship
there might not be enough time for us to
see one of them get married and it
actually makes sense so they might just
make it seem like Sansa or Oriya is
attracted to someone in the end then
they could kind of leave us with an
ambiguous ending that would leave us
thinking one of the stork daughters will
marry in the future and have children I
really don't know how else they would do
this without it seeming rushed but if
you have any ideas leave them down below
the next question is from Doc Robinson
I'm not sure if he saw my question
yesterday but I'm curious to know what
his Davos is purpose for a guy who has
supposedly isn't a fighter he survives
some pretty serious battles for some
reason he's still around what do you
think Davos definitely still has a role
to play for those of you that have never
read the books Davos actually has his
own POV chapters in the books and George
doesn't just give those out to any
character just as an example
Robb Stark was a king and he didn't have
any POV chapters and even Robert
Baratheon was a king and he didn't have
any POV chapters either
but Davos does Davos has had his own
chapter since the second book so
obviously Davos is more important than
some people may think he was more than
just our eyes and ears for Stannis
Baratheon Davos says now coming to his
own and I believe he will survive the
entire series he will continue to advise
whenever he can but in the end I could
see Davos having a much more powerful
position I've always had this feeling
that the Seven Kingdoms will be split up
and become independent again and Davos
will most likely have some sort of
control over one of the kingdoms he is
the perfect man for the job in my
opinion and I think as soon as Cersei is
out of power I think Jon will split the
power up instead of just having one part
and roll over everything once that
happens Davos would be rewarded for
everything that he has done over the
course of the entire series the next
question says do you think people will
know the truth about John being a
Targaryen when he rides a dragon or
finding out he is unburned if that's
possible of course I have noticed a lot
of people are still confused about
whether John is fireproof or not because
he's a Targaryen but if you remember all
the way back in season 1 John actually
burned his hand when he grabbed Lord
Commander Mormont Lantern and he threw
it on the white John badly burned his
hand when he grabbed that and his hand
is burnt even worse in the books he is
always having to flex his hand because
of how bad it was burned so I have to
say John is not fireproof technically
Daenerys is not fireproof either the
only reason why Daenerys has survived
those fires is because of the blood
magic involved but typically she should
not be fireproof at all times and i
believe george RR martin has said this
on multiple occasions but the question
is do I think people will find out John
is a Targaryen when he goes to ride a
dragon I think that would be a cool way
to do the big reveal in front of all the
other characters but it might not be
that shocking now that we've seen half a
dozen other characters get on a dragon
but if he wrote it by himself that would
be pretty damn cool however I think bran
will tell John about his parentage and
privacy then it's gonna be up to John to
tell everyone else I think John may end
up holding a meeting and letting
everyone know but it wouldn't happen
until the very end John being a
Targaryen can complicate things right
now and he doesn't need any added stress
when he knows the knight king is coming
so I think it would be in John's best
interest to keep this a secret until the
right time but that's just my opinion
I do believe John will ride a dragon
though now that there was only two of
them left someone will need to ride the
other dragon in order to keep it from
being taken down as well and obviously
we have already seen John form a bond
with one of the Dragons so I don't see
why he couldn't form a bond with Ragle
who is named after his father I might
add if John would happened to climb on
Ragle before everyone found out he was a
Targaryen then yeah I think everyone who
saw him do this would be like what the
hell how is John riding a dragon on his
own I would like to think they would
assume he has to have some Targaryen
blood
be able to do that and I actually think
that would be a cool way to do that big
reveal
the next question is from flash wave
could Circe do anything in the final
season to redeem herself this is a good
question that I had actually wondered
myself at this point Circe would need to
go above and beyond to get any kind of
redemption she would need to fully
support the north during the great war
against the night king during the dragon
pit scene Circe said she would send all
of our banners north to help them but of
course she was lying but if for some
reason she changed her mind and she
decided to help John and Daenerys that
would definitely be a start toward some
Redemption she would also have to be
willing to step aside by forfeiting the
Iron Throne and I believe if Cersei sent
help to the north and if she stepped
aside from the Iron Throne
they would let her live they would allow
her to go back to Casterly Rock and live
out her days there John and Daenerys
were already willing to play ball with
Cersei because they needed her help and
her men to defeat the knight King if
Cersei would play ball this could go a
long way but we all know Cersei will
never play ball she is already committed
to screwing over everyone in her way I
don't see Cersei ever stepping down as
Queen she will not give up without a
fight she could redeem herself a little
bit if she really wanted to but she
never will she will die before she ever
gives up her position she has made that
pretty clear the next question is from
Raja Norah how would you like Game of
Thrones to end please describe how you
wish it would end I'll try to sum this
up as quickly as possible that way I can
answer some of the other questions
because I could go on for days about how
I would like every storyline to be
wrapped up basically what I really want
is for the ending to make sense I don't
want it to feel too rushed like it did
during season seven I don't expect them
to put a pretty little bow on the end of
every character story but I hope they
can at least and the main plot in a
satisfying way one thing I would like is
for John or one of the other Starks to
produce an error
someone to carry on their name and the
family's legacy and this kind of calls
back to the question I answered earlier
but it would be nice to know there will
be a new generation to carry the torch
if John or Daenerys dies I would like
for them to have a child first there
will more than likely be a bittersweet
ending and if that means some main
characters will die then I would be
satisfied
if they left a child behind history
tends to repeat itself in this story a
lot so Indiana would prefer if the night
King is defeated in epic fashion I don't
want a peace treaty because that would
leave the window open for this cycle to
continue in the future I don't want them
to try and reason with the night King
even if he isn't purely evil he needs to
be stopped for good I'm sorry but I'm a
human so I'm on Team human the night
King gotta go I don't care what his
intentions actually are but worst case
scenario figure out a way to turn him
back into a human again if that's even
possible
I'm expecting the seven kingdoms to be
completely destroyed and in ruins by the
end of the series so it would be nice to
know that the right characters are going
to be left behind that can restore some
sort of normalcy to the realm the final
book is called a dream of spring and
that title sounds like there will be
some hope in the end we may lose most of
the characters we love but I hope enough
good characters are left behind to
rebuild and make Westeros a better and
more civilized place to live even if it
takes an entire generation to rebuild
new laws will need to be put in place
but if people like Davos ginjury Brienne
and Tyrion are still alive then I would
be confident they would be able to do
this Westeros would be left in good
hands those are just some of the things
I would like to see in the end the next
question is from Josh and he asked what
reunion am I most excited to see in
season 8 thanks for the question Josh
this is a pretty easy one for me to
answer though reunion I want to see the
most is a full-on stark reunion I want
to see all of the Starks in one room at
the same time this is something that
needs to happen before the series ends
this is another way I want this series
to end is all of the Starks seeing each
other one last time especially John and
Arya these two have a bond that cannot
be broken
aurilla perfectly demonstrated this in
season 7 when she made sure Sansa wasn't
about to betray Jon in any way John and
arias relationship is about as strong as
all of the Starks relationships were
with their dire wolves in the books John
an aria think about each other all the
time they miss each other more than any
of the other siblings and it will be
really nice to see these two get to hug
each other again I can't wait to see the
smile on John's face when he sees Arya
still has neo at her side
I feel like this will be one of the
reunions that could actually make me cry
next season and I won't feel ashamed for
doing so even Sansa said so herself John
is gonna freak out when he sees Arya
again I personally can't wait for this
but all of the Starks reuniting will
fill very satisfying it was the first
family we were introduced to and they're
the family that I love the most the next
question says do you believe that Varys
betrayed Daenerys how did Cersei and
Jaime know Daenerys Centurions war plans
thank you for the question Lana I'm not
exactly sure if Varys has betrayed
Daenerys already but I do believe Varys
will betray her at some point next
season there were a few things that were
said to Varys over the last two seasons
that made me believe he will die because
of a betrayal the first person to
question Varys was kin Vera and she told
Varys that as long as he supports the
Narus then he has nothing to fear from
the red priests then she also asked
various if he wanted to know what was
said in the flames and this scared his
[ __ ] out of Eros I think in vara knows
Varys will double-cross the queen and it
has something to do with what was said
to him in the flames beerus his own
death may have been revealed to him as a
little boy but he doesn't want to
believe it but when can Vora mentioned
the flames to him they scared him
because it made it even more real then
Melisandre told Varys he was going to
die in Westeros she didn't say when so
technically he could die as an old man
but they wouldn't have had Melisandre
say that to Varys unless it was gonna
happen soon
Varys his death will be connected to
Melisandre or Canberra and I think he
has known this ever since he was a
little boy this is why he hates magic
and any red priest he meets Daenerys
also told Varys that never betray her or
else she would burn him with her dragons
and I believe all of this is
foreshadowing Varys is betrayal to me
that just feels like the direction
they're going to go in but I could be
wrong like I said but I think this is a
good place to stop today's video I want
to thank everyone for posting your
questions I really appreciate that I
will be uploading another video tomorrow
so I hope to see you all come back for
that one I also want to thank all of my
new patreon supporters much love to
everyone that has signed up and helped
this channel have a great day everyone
I'll see you soon
by
Oh